hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreigner again today is
Thursday but it is also the release of
season 10 so now we get to play Sakura
as well or hito kiri whatever you want
to call her as well as playing the
Raider rework the wahlburger rubric and
everything else that comes within the
game for season 10
so roughly after this video goes live it
should be up and I will be streaming
here on YouTube so just keep an eye on
the channel and we'll be playing some
hito kiri maybe with a couple of the
youtube friends and stuff like that so
we'll be having a nice chill-out session
so definitely come around for that but
for the stream it was a pretty short
stream but we got some interesting news
to talk about today one of them being a
new road map for the week for the month
of May and there really isn't much
happening in the beginning month of May
which kind of sucks but there is really
no issue with that for example we're
gonna gonna be getting an XP fest on May
10th which is next week so if you want
to rank up your heat so kiri or any
other character that you have you can
definitely utilize that weekend other
than that we have your standard content
of the week your arcade quests your
Slayer challenges for the week and a new
playlist in the events tab called hyper
duel and then one on the 16th which is
blurred out which I don't understand
I've never seen the other game-mode
hyper duel before and we also have no
clue of what's coming on May 16th what
I'm assuming these will be event
game-mode seeing is that part of the
event playlist I think hyper duel is
gonna be some type of realistic duel
duels of a feats or maybe less health
when I think of the word of hyper I
think of fast so maybe they want these
duel matches to go faster I don't know
it's obviously not going to be within
the real game and it's only going to be
just an event playlist so this is where
they can kind of screw around and do a
lot more weirder things with certain
game modes so that's what I'm assuming
we might be able to use feats in duels
but that is just my interpretation of
this this could be totally off from what
it actually is and as for the one that's
blurred you really can't tell what it is
but I hope it's just a cool game uh
that's all I can really add to that but
let me know what you guys think hyper
duel and this new game-mode is gonna be
in the comments below
next up in temple garden they actually
had a change in the map this season they
removed that middle structure which I
believe is a tomb on the a spawn which
is the one up on that little watchtower
and they also took a and they made a
slope to make the ladder a little bit
smaller for the a side spawn as to
create a little bit of balance on each
side because as you know if you've
played temple garden if you spawn on
that area and try to go to that
objective it's gonna be a lot harder and
the enemies will most likely beat you
because all they have to do is run
through a little Hut and go some stairs
law you have to take your time in the
ladder and being on the ladder you're
not gaining anywhere you're not going
forward you're just taking your time
building up and that's a lot less time
for you to actually get that objective
and beat that team and as well most
tournaments and for honor are located
around this area and temple garden so
they changed up the 2v2 setting it used
to be directly in the middle of a map
and all the players had to move out into
that area so now they just change it so
that for to be too broad this could also
be in dual as well but at least in 2v2
brawl that's where this area is gonna be
set up as to make tournament smoother
and just to make it look a little bit
nicer and then lastly to end the video
we have the new content of the week
which is a free roam emo called
soluti or but really it's basically just
tea posing they're actually tea posing
in for honor now so this is pretty
incredible I didn't actually think this
would exist but I guess it's here now
and I can't wait to pie this one of
these season goes live so if you want to
assert your dominance on the battlefield
with your tea opposing emotes you can
buy this at 7,000 steel available for
all heroes and each of them have their
own unique version some do spin
techniques some are just more
professional with laying the sword down
and doing the pose or somewhere like
Highlander where he drops his sword in
his foot and other weird things I
believe JJ like breaks his back because
of all old vias so some little quirky
things that are put into each of the
emotes which is really nice I'm assuming
the emote video hasn't finished yet by
the time I'm talking it so what I'm
going to be doing is just do my outro
and if the video happens to go a little
bit longer we'll just keep that going
until that's the end yeah guys like the
V if you do enjoy subscribe if you're
new let me know your thoughts on season
10 I believe by the time this video
should be up season 10 should be up
right now hopefully by the time this is
up so you can go in play some heat so
carry the Raider Raider rework the
wahlburger rework all the stuff that is
involved with season 10 the new weapons
and all that great stuff that you can
play so if you do want to go do that do
that immediately after you watch this
video and like I said I will be
streaming so if you want to maybe watch
it the stream on your phone while you
grind yourself I'll be totally cool with
that
yeah like I said like the V if you do
enjoy subscribe if you're new I covered
the informational side of foreigner that
bean balance changes hero updates patch
notes and leaks so if you want to be
kept up to date with everything
happening within the world
for honor I never miss out on an update
definitely stay subscribed to the
channel for that and without my too much
justin videos are gonna be popping up on
the screen during the outro and take
care guys have a great rest today
enjoy season 10 and drove the tipos
emote and peace out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]